joining us now the man who coached in
New Orleans Saints to a championship in
Super Bowl 44 and some would say he's
doing his best coaching job yet this
year he is Sean Payton Sean welcome back
to the program how are you I'm doing
well Mike thanks for having me on hey
when you get the kind of praise you're
getting this year for pushing the team
to win after win after win after win
even without your starting quarterback
and people say it may be your best job
yet what's your reaction well look
sometimes I mean honestly it's it's
something that is really more reflection
of just the whole group here then the
group of players in this locker room I
mean our coaching staff you know we
started off the season with the win and
had a tough loss at Los Angeles and drew
went down with the injury and I think
the best thing we did was we had planned
to stay out west so after that Ram game
we flew to Seattle and got in there late
Sunday night and we were there for a
week in a hotel and you know I I think
they're they're pivotable I mean they're
games that you can look at that that are
turning-point games if you will for a
team that was a big win for us on the
road Seattle and the early stretch of
that schedule was was difficult but you
know guys kind of came together and and
and in Drew's absence you know they kind
of battled and and we were able to win
Teddy to his credit came in and each
week played better and better and so
look to your question it's such a team
sport
there and I and I understand the
individual the individual recognition
that goes out to either players or
coaches and and yet for me I just feel
like there's so many people here that
have that contribute to the early start
of this season we got a lot of football
ahead of us but you know hopefully we
can keep pushing and and find a way to
get in the postseason again how will
that momentum that you developed while
Drew was injured how will that help down
the stretch if at all well look I think
there's a confidences is funny and I
think that I've heard this said before
you know you can wish for it you can
think it
you can say you're going to be confident
but it really it's a result of
demonstrated ability on the field you
there's certain things you have to do
then to say hey I'm confident I can do
that again I'm confident I can continue
to do that and and I think during that
stretch and and even even up till now we
can week out good teams
I think gain confidence and their
behavior on the field and in the way
they play
I talked to cam Jordan after one of your
victories this year and he credited the
defensive performance to the fact that
everyone for the most part has been
together for three years now and one of
the key ingredients they're keeping
defensive coordinator Dennis Allen whose
contract expired after the 2018 season
in hindsight how important was that to
the team to keep him around yeah I think
very important and in back to the
question you asked earlier I mean the
efforts of Dennis and his staff and the
guys on offense and Deron Rizzi and his
group on defense you know there's a lot
a lot of hours being put in da is is
someone that should I've known since oh
six he was on our original staff here
and I'd listen I don't think Dennis was
going anywhere
laterally as a defensive coordinator
clearly if he gets an opportunity and
I'm sure he will at some point to be a
head coach again then you know you wish
him well and but we're fortunate to have
him he's a tremendous teacher a real
good communicator and a good friend
receiver michael thomas on pace to break
the single season reception record held
by Marvin Harrison what does he do best
I would say his physicality at the
release or at the top of routes
depending on how you choose to play him
if you're gonna press him boy he is he's
extremely physical at the line of
scrimmage and if you're gonna play off
you know he's going to be explosive at
the top end of routes I think he has
strong hands in traffic those would be
just a few things and his run after the
catch ability is exceptional we talked
earlier about the fact that even though
it's a team sport there are individual
accolades no receiver has ever been
named NFL MVP there's some discussion of
him as
fringe candidate based on what he's
doing and also based on the fact that
with Drew Brees out five games it's hard
for the quarterback to be in the MVP
conversation make the case for Michael
Thomas as a potential NFL MVP well look
it starts with you got a win we hear the
things we know you got to be a winning
team you got to be generally speaking
having success and he's been a huge part
of that for us then you have to have
production in he's on pace to have more
production at that position and than
anyone in the history of the game and
then lastly our Super Bowl champion just
had the MVP at receiver so there's no
reason that can't happen relative to the
length of a season the intensity and
focus that I see from Michael Thomas
especially before games I feel like he's
been there long enough now that that
intensity that passion that drive I get
the impression it's spilling over to
some of the other players how much of
what he brings to the game is infectious
and does influence the guys who are new
to your program well I think a lot I
think they see how he practices in the
preparation you know he's probably his
own worst critic by far you can get hard
on himself to practice but every rep so
important to him starting from the
beginning of the week walked through the
last great questions and all the way up
to game time and there's just a standard
that he wants to play to and that he's
comfortable with and that and that's
kind of how he plays - with the chip on
his shoulder when are you more nervous
during a game when you're up a score
late or when you're down a score late I
would say not during a game it's it's
generally the half an hour an hour prior
to the game you're anxious you just yeah
once the game gets started there's
excitement but you're kind of focused in
the moment and you've been going
generally at least for me you know the
the anxiety the anticipation all of that
is pregame there's plenty of discussion
about analytics and how that influences
decisions that are made in the moment by
the head coach I talked earlier today to
Tony Dungy about the decision
on Thursday night by the Colts to go for
it on fourth and seven and we got into a
broader talk about analytics and I'm
curious coach how do you incorporate the
percentages the the numbers the
statistics the charts into the decisions
you make during the heat of the moment
during the course of a game I think
what's most important is understanding
which ones you don't want to pay
attention to in other words there's
there's you have a lot of information
but what is it that that you look at
that that means something substantial
because different than baseball you know
in our game you might have an injury or
your left tackles having trouble
blocking the defensive end so that the
the numbers compute to say you need to
go forward here but those those aren't
accounting for the injury at left tackle
or the pressure your quarterbacks having
or there's so many other factors rather
than just an at-bat versus a pitcher
left-handed right-handed
however there there are some things that
are extremely important and Ryan Herman
in our department here each week will do
several reports will do a keys to
victory analytics report separate from
our regular keys to victory in other
words outside the box thinking here's
what he would say relative to what he's
seen from the opponents so I think more
importantly than anything which ones
which specifically do we want to pay
attention to and which ones do we want
to ignore there's one specific aspect of
analytics that has come into focus over
the past couple of years
it applies when you're down by 14 now
you're not often down by 14 so it's not
relevant to you all that frequently but
the idea that when you're down 14 you
score a touchdown you go 4-2 to cut it
to 6 because the next touchdown plus a 1
pointer puts you ahead we've seen
multiple coaches do that Matt Patricia
did it last week with the Lions do you
have a standard rule that you would
apply if you're down 14 and you score
that touchdown to go for 1 or go for 2
well it wouldn't that be the same if
you're down 7 meaning we're going to
before
pay attention to that stat line and
let's say you and I today are going to
agree that we're gonna we're going to do
that then when we're down seven in score
aren't we going for two in other words a
lot of it has to depend on do you feel
like it's a higher scoring game or not I
mean if I feel like my team's playing
better and that I might not put put
ourselves in that position for not
making a two point play
I also think here's the one thing that
that I think a lot of times they fail to
understand you have a certain amount of
place you want to run from the two in
you might call them your two point play
list you might have three of them well
if you like them as two point plays and
you're down on the two or the three yard
line are you going to call one of them
in the first or second quarter for a
touchdown and you'd say yes if you like
that play a lot then I might call that
play in the second quarter and so there
are weeks where when you get to the
fourth quarter I feel like I can't wait
to get to one of these plays two-point
play or inside the three yard line and
there have been weeks where you've
you've used a couple and now so a lot
goes into it but to answer your question
I don't know why 14 is different than 7
or 21 it's a good point though about the
plays you have available and that's
something that I've made in the past if
you don't have a two-point play you feel
good about in that moment that's a
factor in whether or not you're going to
go for two whether you're down seven
whether you're down 14 whatever the gap
is you got to feel good about it you've
already used your best two-point play
earlier in the game then there it goes
and I think that gets overlooked when we
get caught up in percentages and numbers
you got to feel good about the play
you're going to call or it makes no
sense to call it right in and look we
just finished going through this last
night you know here's our tight red zone
here are 2-point plays but I guarantee
in the second quarter Sunday against
Carolina if we get down to the two or
three I kind of know what play I want to
call and if I like it that much well I'm
not going to wait and say I'm saving
this for my fourth-quarter two-point
play I'm going to score six points with
it if I can in the second quarter
you mentioned Carolina they've got
running back Christian McCain
he's having a great year his skills are
comparable to Alvin cámaras McCaffrey
gets a lot more work he gets a lot more
touches so he generates more yards more
touchdowns more notoriety how tempting
is it for you and how hard is it to
resist the temptation to use Alvin
Kamara in that same workhorse way that
the Panthers used Christian McCaffrey
well look i think in credit Carolina and
Ron those guys have done a great job
he's having a fantastic year and and I
would say this is the first year we've
seen him in that that true halfback
predominant running back 98% of the game
because he too has been a guy that is
opened up and played in the empty sets
and done a number of different things a
lot of it just has to do with how your
game is unfolding but for me you know I
think we've got two real good backs
Alvin's certainly someone that I feel is
special and is really important to what
we do and there's going to be weeks
where we lean on him everything than
others but relative to the amount or the
playing percentage I think a lot of it
is is your long-term vision durability
and and having someone that's fresh and
ready to carry the load when Alvin got
hurt this year missed a few games
latavius jumped in and was fantastic
we're talking on a Friday morning you're
gonna play two games within the next six
days how does the fact that you've got a
short week coming up after the Carolina
game affect in any way your preparations
for Carolina well our preparations this
week have been pretty standard you know
we played a game Sunday at Tampa came
back home you know had our normal Monday
routine players off Tuesday and
Wednesday began the work week where the
routine switches a little is coming off
the the game Sunday these guys will be
down on Monday we'll spend a lot of time
in meetings and then walkthrough we just
played Atlanta two weeks ago so coming
up we're at least understanding the
opponent will be helpful but I think it
becomes a little bit more of a mental
prep test during that short week and
then trying to get these guys off their
feet and recovered as quickly as
possible
you know I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about the replay review for Pat
interference given your experience in
January given your on the competition
committee what's your assessment of
where that protocol for reviewing pass
interference calls and non calls
currently is and what if anything do you
think needs to be changed as we get
deeper into the season and approach the
playoffs well I'm obviously here we are
ten weeks in or whatnot in clearly
there's this bar that's higher than
probably any of us anticipated in other
words the standard for a play to be
overturned is higher than then then
certainly than I expected and so we pay
attention to it that's how it's being
called we understand it and then we go
from there from it from a standpoint of
change I think there are there are a
dozen or so plays that we're going to
look at and say how was this not
overturned and so we just have to have
the fortitude enough to say hey this
this this wasn't the right call and
we're gonna and so I think that's a
challenge for al it's a challenge for
the New York when we go to New York and
quite honestly I think you know that the
numbers looking at those plays from a
consistency standpoint need to be it's
hard to be singular in that position
it's hard for one person last night when
we meet on a phase of our game you know
there's going to be four or five voices
that can that can have thoughts and
opinions and I think they can help you
arrive at a better decision than quietly
one person and I think al does a great
job and yet I think that number needs to
be more of three or five where we're
looking at it and we're taking in all
the things that we've discussed but
clearly there's a standard right now and
we just have to pay attention to right
now because that applies to everyone
right but how does this complicate your
decision in the heat of the moment when
you got your hand on that red bean bag
and you got to decide whether or not
you're gonna toss it onto the field and
you know what's gonna happen because we
don't we don't know I mean I think it's
fair to say we don't know where the line
is we don't know where it is
Southwind at home we know
you know it's above our head all right
so we know it's got to be clear and then
the other thing that happens last week
at Tampa there's a play interference
which it look like upstairs we don't
have anything yet coach what's it look
like they're going to the line of
scrimmage nothing here and so we don't
always get a feed you know you're
hopeful that you get a feed and so
there's some there's some gut there's
some instincts but based on what I know
today week ten I know it's there's gonna
have to be it's gonna have to be pretty
clear and obvious or it's gonna it's
gonna be as called on the field and and
so that's just it's a high high standard
and I think that if you feel like now
that doesn't prevent if I feel like
there's been a pass interference or that
wasn't interference that I'm throwing
the challenge flag and then I'm gonna be
pissed off if I wasn't right hey before
I let you go you've got the post season
looming and I know you haven't gotten
your berth yet so this is a hypothetical
assuming that you make it to the
playoffs will you approach the playoffs
any differently given the way that the
post season ended for your team each of
the last two years
man we played well III don't I mean I
would not change my preparations for the
post season based on the play digs made
in Minnesota that would be madness and
then I think no I like the way this
team's prepared I'd like the way this
team has been kind of fought through
some adversity and and you know
hopefully fortunately if we're able to
get into that position I think we'll
have a plan on how we prepare each
preach game but holy cow that's that's
the other thing back to the analytics so
often you make adjustments and you got
to make sure you're fixing the right
part and you're not just fixing a
muffler and you got a tire problem coach
we wish you the best moving forward the
rest of the season we look forward to
seeing on NBC next Thursday night in
Atlanta taking on the Falcons and we
look forward also seeing you in the
postseason this year congratulations on
all your success this season and hope to
talk to you again real soon
thanks a bunch Mike appreciate you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports